hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
ah
I'm just checking in on you
just checking in to see how it's going
the first week of 2023
holidays are over
you know you got to do that sad thing of
taking down the tree
ah
is there anything sadder than taking
down the tree you feel great though when
it's all over
when all the decorations and
everything's put away there is a certain
level of relief but taking them all down
you know you feel like you lost an
election
you're working first I always pictured
that like you know
what that must be like to like lose like
a pres a presidential election
like you're to the point where most of
the Free World actually is kind of
knowing your name if you're you know the
standing president re-running the
everybody knows your [ __ ] name and
all of a sudden you lose and all those
glad handers
slapping you on the back yeah the Elvis
Entourage you tell a little joke A Guy
Walks six Paces over to a wall and slaps
it as if anything has ever been that
funny
uh which is something I maintain nothing
has ever been so funny that you had to
run out of a room
um some of these TV shows you'll see
somebody will make a joke and then they
themselves actually run out of the room
which to me I feel is sort of the end
zone dance
of telling a joke or maybe those idiots
who get like a first down
or my favorite my favorite you're down
by 20 and you stop the running back for
like a one-yard loss and you get up
flexing and stomping around
for whatever [ __ ] I don't even know what
it because I guess you know give a [ __ ]
that the team's gonna lose
is that what it is oh Old man bill
that's not gonna change the name to this
podcast too Bill complains about [ __ ]
all right here's some new [ __ ] that's
out that I'm sick of people complaining
about Teslas
all right I know the guy that runs it's
a [ __ ] laminated face [ __ ] we all
know that we all know he's a nerd who's
trying to be cool now hey I'm smoking a
joint hey I got wacky things to say
about stuff you know stay in your lane
get back in chemistry class and [ __ ]
do something with a beaker whatever the
[ __ ] it is you brainiacs do
he's trying to be the life of the party
that's where we are in this country
right now the [ __ ] nerds are trying
to [ __ ] put the lampshade on their
head
you don't put the lampshade on the head
you design the lamp
um
anyway oh my God
does anybody you don't need to hear more
from is the Tesla guy oh what does the
Tesla guy think about this let's think
of all of his wacky ideas with tunnels
and all of this [ __ ]
just go do it maybe he's like trying to
drum up more money is that what it is
I don't know what but I'm sick of people
[ __ ] on the Tesla
all these gas combustion people these
[ __ ] idiots going like
I could fill up my tank of gas in 10
minutes
I don't need a half hour and a big papa
it's like hey [ __ ] you have a
charger at your house imagine if you had
a gas pump at your house
right
and every morning you woke up with a
full tank of [ __ ] gas
stop acting like stopping for gas two
three times a [ __ ] week isn't a pain
in the end especially if you're on a
budget if you're putting in five here
ten bucks here whatever you do right
you're forever going to a gas station
and there's that stupid [ __ ]
right well you know there's like there's
like two people almost done filling up
their gas tank and you're and you're two
cars behind and you're sitting there
praying to God that the person in front
of you is clocking this
all right and what happens is the guy
the the first guy
he pulls out meaning the second car in
line and goes around the other guy who's
just finishing up and what is the [ __ ]
do in front of you do they wait and just
wait for that person all the way in the
front to get the last couple of drops of
gas in to pull off so then they pull all
the way up and you can get in there no
no they do not they pull right in get
out their dumb fat ass starts pumping
the car and you're looking at them like
what the [ __ ] and their big gulp brain
never puts two and two together don't
act like that isn't happening
all right
they're [ __ ] incredible cars that are
as fast as a [ __ ] motorcycle with
people and groceries in them and then
what do they do they show videos of like
look at when you put it in self-driving
mode it ended up hitting something how
does your car do in self-driving mode oh
that's right it doesn't have one
all right they're gonna figure it out
all right
and this gun up and piece of people that
are gonna have to die along the way how
do you think we got to where we're at in
aviation
scuba diving
bridge building people [ __ ] died
and you know what I bet right along the
way write a [ __ ] Kitty Hawk there was
some [ __ ] sitting there on their horses
going say that's why you know
die right now you know my horse doesn't
leave the ground and I don't [ __ ]
dope right
meanwhile you get thrown off it like
Christopher Reeves and break your
[ __ ] neck but nobody brings that up
do they
ah Bill did you have to go off on
Superman I loved Christopher Reeve all
right he's dead his suffering is over
you know
I wonder if he would have done the
self-driving thing I mean I think if
you're crazy enough to play polo
I mean the [ __ ] that can happen to you
on a horse anyway the fact that you're
leaning over with a croquet Mallet I
mean it's just [ __ ]
isn't that inevitable
I'll tell you one of the most [ __ ] up
ones ever was the uh
was it Bill Shoemaker
the guy rode horses his whole [ __ ]
career never broke his neck then [ __ ]
got in a car got in a car accident and
then broke his [ __ ] neck
it wasn't that part of that Alanis
Morissette song
isn't it ironic don't you think
do you want to hear my Alanis Morissette
joke from [ __ ] 25 years ago when that
song came out you know that one where
she came off like it was so funny like
she was sitting there bitching about her
ex-boyfriend just coming off like the
kind of person you would break up with
but she was just going like hey
right and she said that line you know
did you forget about me Mr dude
and there was a would she go down on you
in a theater
talking about his new girlfriend would
she go down and you in the theater it's
like no she wouldn't
I'm gonna marry her you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
sorry
all right every once in a while like I
go for Big Air I go for Big Air and I
miss the ramp
um
you don't marry a woman that blows you
in a movie theater
um oh geez I got an incoming call here I
hope this isn't gonna [ __ ] with the
podcast hang on a second
um
all right I'm back from the phone call
shaking that off now what if a guy went
down on a woman in a movie theater would
she marry him all depends on what he's
making
and that's what it comes down to
everybody okay that's how it's done
um out here in the streets
um it's been raining that's why this
podcast is a little [ __ ] up it's been
raining for like I don't know how many
days out here which is great
you know La we need the rain we need the
rain to watch it go down the LA River
and just go out to the [ __ ] ocean so
these stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] can then
tell us that we're in another drought
why don't you guys I don't I still don't
you don't every time you go like why
don't you [ __ ]
Corral is that the right word with the
liquid or do you do that with a solid
like a like a like cattle you Corral
cattle
you gather nuts and berries what the
[ __ ] do you do with water whatever that
means is stick it in a giant container
whatever that [ __ ] word is why don't
they do that and they oh there's no
money in it
all the money is in destroying the
planet I don't understand how to use
title you turn that one around
maybe Elon Tesla can work on that one
um anyway uh
the [ __ ] else am I wanted to talk about
oh so the other night you know I'm
taping the bills Bengals game
right and I'm watching the garbage truck
videos with my uh my little boy and all
of a sudden I get a text message like oh
my God are you watching the Bills game
so sad and I'm thinking like oh my god
what happened to the bills now
you know I mean every time they go in a
positive I'm thinking you know they pick
six
you know Josh Allen you know [ __ ]
blew out his ACL I had you know
in 50 years of watching football
that has never happened I don't think
that's ever happened like the odds
of that
um
unbelievable I'm glad I wasn't watching
it because I just saw like the
highlights and the looks on the players
faces and everything I'm kind of glad
that by the time I saw it I knew that
they had gotten that poor kid to the
hospital and even though he's in
critical condition at least he's there
with
you know
you know the the people that know what
they're doing yeah bill it's called a
hospital all right thank you
I will tell you the one funny thing
about it though all right and this is a
comedy podcast so you have to go with
this all right I have it's my job
to find the knock knock joke within the
horror the funniest thing was I heard
this this lady
on ESPN
and she was uh
she was talking about like how close the
Buffalo Bills are
she goes you know of course they're
distraught this is a really close team
you know there's not a lot to do out
here in Buffalo and blah blah and I just
burst it out laughing it's like did she
just low-key trash Buffalo
it was just picture him like hey Josh
what do you want to do
you want to go get some more Wings ah
man I can't I can't carry my wings
uh what do you want to do I want you
come home play Madden right then they
hang out
like hey Josh you ever feel like you
know
it's not like I don't feel lucky but you
ever feel like playing for the bills you
kind of don't feel like you're in the
NFL when you play a home game
but then when you go on the road you're
like oh yeah that's right I am in the
NFL but like when you play a home game
you have a
you ever just kind of feel like you may
be like in
in like the CFL or something you have a
feeling I mean I mean Canada is right
there you ever think that Josh
oh yeah yeah
I guess I kind of do
I'm I'm glad you shared that with me I I
feel closer to you
anyway
um
I don't know I don't know what else to
talk about that's just a [ __ ]
horrific situation but I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious that even during that
time someone still
had to take a [ __ ] shot
at Buffalo now there's no [ __ ] way
there's not a lot to do in Buffalo I've
been to Buffalo okay there's plenty of
places to drink there's plenty of good
food
okay I don't know who's making the
tables out there but they got to be
making a killing
um they got a minor league ballpark out
there that was very impressive
I mean [ __ ] Rick James lived out
there there must have been some fun to
have right
um I wonder if she got any [ __ ] for that
I'm just gonna say that during a time
like this when thoughts and prayers
should be thoughts and praying
in the Buffalo direction for you to make
fun of you're killing our tourism
they got Niagara Falls
they used to be an amazing thing to go
see you know but now you can watch like
[ __ ] beheading videos
you know
while you're on the [ __ ] I mean it
takes a lot
to get people to go is that one of the
wonders of the world
what an innocent type
you know when they actually had wonders
of the world
like I wonder how this happened
you know now there's just answers
there's always some douche that's got to
be standing there giving you all the
[ __ ] answers
look at this
look at the Grand Canyon
this is one of the wonders of the world
well actually it was created by during
the Ice Age shut up
can't you just let me be stupid
underrated
not knowing [ __ ]
right just [ __ ] sitting there
drinking a Slurpee
eating something that's leading you to a
[ __ ] heart attack there really is
something to be said about staying dumb
you know
you always think you got the answers
everything's easy
like it's got to be really difficult to
be [ __ ] like smart you know like a
scientist
right first of all not only not yeah now
you're going to get signed on by some
[ __ ]
Corporation you sign like the studio
deals like actors back in the day in the
40s and 50s you sign on and they're
going to get credit they get credit and
they own everything that you [ __ ]
create
you know when you sell your soul
right
probably got to bring your own [ __ ]
microscope cheap [ __ ]
and you get in there and you got all of
these mouth breathing morons with no
[ __ ] background whatsoever
questioning
your work like let's take uh Elon Tesla
there right he's making the [ __ ] cars
that drive themselves now I don't know
why he's doing that
I don't know why we [ __ ] need that I
have no idea I just hope the satellite
will make the [ __ ] in front of me move
all the way up to the other gas pump oh
no we won't even be at gas pumps to the
other charger
is that is that what it's going to be
um
when they were talking about
self-driving cars like morons were
posting pictures
of train tracks
like oh
just [ __ ] doing this
or like why don't you just take a train
people who don't take trains were saying
we already have these things they're
called trains people who didn't design a
train people who like the train already
exists and if everybody who is involved
in training died
you ever think about that if all of
these people that run all of this [ __ ]
if they all [ __ ] die none of us would
know how to get it going again
we just watch it all
fall apart be like that's an airplane
dad knows how to fly if you know how to
do it
I'm in a weird mood I I am I am here to
defend
Buffalo I've always had a good time
when I've gone out there and uh Buffalo
is a lot like Philadelphia
where in Philadelphia when you go there
right you're like you just think man
nobody here knows how to read
it's just this overwhelming thought that
this is just a high level
of illiteracy and the only other place
that I feel that is when I go to
Baltimore I mean sorry Buffalo well
Baltimore too
Jesus Christ even every day how many
times they're going to try to build up
the [ __ ] Bay
it's like it's over nobody's going down
there enough with the neon lights in the
themed restaurants
no I don't think that I'm saying when
you go to Philly
it's the locals call it
you ask anybody in Philadelphia where to
get the best cheesesteak and every one
of them says someplace different you go
to Buffalo you ask them where should I
go
should I go to Duffy's or should I go to
that other [ __ ] Anchor Bar and they
both look at you like no you don't go
either place that's where the tourists
go and that's like when whenever they
show those stupid [ __ ] cheesesteak
places in Philly they always show uh uh
genos pets or genos whatever the [ __ ] it
is
I guess all of those
are like the Times Square
of both of those cities like you don't
go there
um
and you know what's funny about all of
that [ __ ] is it's not you know if you
didn't if you don't live there
it's not really that good
you know what I mean it's like poor
qualities of meat
it gives you a [ __ ] heart attack you
can't [ __ ] move after you eat it
there's really no reason past a certain
age
to eat it unless you grew up there
because you have that child sense memory
like the amount of [ __ ] food
in Boston that every time I go back and
eat and immediately wish that I didn't
but while I'm eating it
like I go back to being six seven eight
years old
right not a care in the [ __ ] world
not a care in the [ __ ] world no debt
no [ __ ] problems just sitting there
at McDonald's eating a [ __ ]
cheeseburger whatever the [ __ ] we used
to go
you know
and you just all you're doing is just
going back to oh my God
I was young I had a full head of hair I
didn't have somebody bitching at me I
had no [ __ ] deadline and the food
reminds you of how free you were before
you got sucked into the Matrix so then
what happens is Taurus comes to your
town like Boston and I tell these people
hey you know where you gotta go you
gotta go here to get this it's [ __ ]
amazing and then my friends always go
there how oh my God you like it and
they're always like yeah it was all
right
you know bread was a little you know
bread wasn't that great I'm like what
are you talking about you start
you start getting all upset
like I saw two comedians on a podcast
arguing about what was better
a Cheesesteak or a steak and cheese and
I'm from Massachusetts so I'm like
without a doubt it's a steak and cheese
but at the end of the day
nobody from Philly or Massachusetts
could tell you what part of the cow that
meat is coming from
I'm going to guess the hoof
having said all that every time I go to
Philly I get a Cheesesteak every time I
go to Buffalo I get wings
and every time I go to Boston
I get a steak and cheese
and that's just it
and that's how it's gonna be
and I am just staying
at a nice dumb level
of cuisine
I like doing that I'm like this you know
this infused this that infused it I'm
not into that [ __ ] I like the straight
heart attack
you ever see interviews of Jackie
Gleason like right before he died the
guy's literally sitting there he's got
like a high ball glass with some sort of
booze in it and he's smoking a [ __ ]
cigarette and you're looking at him like
this guy is gonna drop at any second
he knows it I in the whole [ __ ] world
knows it and he didn't give a [ __ ]
there's really something to be said
about that is everybody's sitting there
trying to eat healthy and organic food
and all that it's like oh
you could go the other way
you could go the other way and just not
give a [ __ ]
right
and just smoke and drink
and [ __ ] and sock sorry when Tony
Montana there
can you imagine just like never going to
a heart doctor
and just being like 50 pounds overweight
and just ordering a hot fudge sundae
like how fun would that be
you know
bringing you know because you're so full
of [ __ ] salt from whatever [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just ate
I don't know I'm probably thinking all
of this because it's the first 10 days
of the month when I go on my little
[ __ ] thing here
you know
just so I can prove to myself that I
have some sort of control in my life
[Laughter]
um and isn't that what we all want to
feel
um anyway
and through the magic of editing I'm now
driving down the street
not in a Tesla I'm doing it myself
um
oh [ __ ] what else was I talking I was
talking about here's a way to die that
has gone out
you know if you're not gonna die like
Jackie Gleason where you're just like
listen I'm eating [ __ ] steak every
night I'm smoking a cigarette whenever
my body tells me to and I'm gonna polish
it off with a nice glass of [ __ ]
bourbon if you don't mind sir
here's one that that's gone away with
the times you know back in the day an
admirable way to go out was drowning in
your own puke
it was just a way that so many you know
everyone wanted to be a rock star and
that was just that was the way
that's the way they went out
and somewhere along the line it got
somehow defined as alcoholism
and that it was this sad thing
but it wasn't it was
I mean it was but it was also was great
for the environment
you know it's also a great way to become
a legend
if you die before people realize what a
[ __ ] you are like they're gonna lay it
on thick
they're gonna lay you know all your
friends are still alive
so they'll talk about how great you are
I'm not now listen I am not advocating
drowning in your own puke I'm just
saying it's just child sense memory
when it comes to this type of stuff
that's got to be the ugliest [ __ ]
house I've ever seen in my life they're
just they're building it right now
Jesus Christ they look like a [ __ ]
Arby's
um
do you know that's one of the [ __ ] up
things out here in La is just the lack
of zoning laws like you can just
basically build whatever the [ __ ] you
want
it's the only city I've ever been to
there'll be like a strip mall next to an
old lady's house and then there'll be a
skyscraper and then after that there'll
be some little hamburger stand
yeah you know whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do go ahead and do it
well give a [ __ ]
um
sorry I'm slowly going crazy here
because uh
I was already I was I was
you know
bedridden during my Williams and
pneumonia's face that my wife's so
eloquently put
and now I'm actually up and about
and I I feel like I want to [ __ ] go
out and go do some [ __ ]
and uh I don't know I've been laying in
a dark room for a few weeks and now now
the [ __ ]
it's all overcast out so I think I'm
getting a little uh little [ __ ] stir
crazy but I think it's the sun's
supposed to come back
on Friday
that would be a nice thing
out here you know what amazes me though
is if I had a plane
and I was instrument rated I could just
fly
just above this ship
you know and how when you're underneath
it you don't think the sun is out
Sun's always out
you're just on the wrong side of the
clouds man
and I think that that's what this is
about where is that siren coming from
look at that fat [ __ ] getting out of his
car
he's one of those fat guys that embraced
it you know what I mean he's just
dressing like he's in a biker gang and
just got out of a [ __ ] Kia
look at this guy diagonally jaywalking
Olympic level
holding on to his puffy coat you can't
zip it up anymore can you you got to
hold it together
holding it together am I the only one
hearing a siren right now oh there it is
all right I'm getting over
getting over oh it's just the ambulance
somebody ended a great life
with a hot fudge sundae right to the
[ __ ] arteries
um
anyway
this would be a perfect day to go out
and get a cup of coffee or two you know
strike up a conversation with somebody
old if you went to the right [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know now that I'm making fun of the
architecture I've never noticed there's
so many [ __ ] Banks and churches out
here
I commend anybody that still goes to
[ __ ] Church
that's that's a that's a really uh I
think that's a really cool thing to do I
might start going back to church
you know but I think when I go back
and like nobody notices that I left I
don't know that my ego will be able to
handle it
so they'll be like [ __ ] this place man
Jesus was Portuguese man and then I'll
walk out feeling like a badass
um
oh there's one of those pickup trucks
that I hate the four-door pickup truck
with the four foot bed
and it's like what what is that
is that a giant El Camino
is it a station wagon that lost its
[ __ ] hatchback is that what like
either buy a [ __ ] truck
hey Bill maybe people can buy the truck
they want maybe there's all different
kinds of designs
why can people only buy the pickup truck
that you deem Worthy
oh I'll tell you why because I am I'm a
white guy in his 50s
therefore I think everyone should live
by my rules
um
you know what I do love seeing I love
seeing a retiree on a porch
you know
just sitting there watching it going by
I always wonder what they're thinking
you know what I mean
I feel like if you live longer
you're actually sort of like appreciate
life well there's somebody still with
their Christmas lights up all right nice
I like that I don't like these [ __ ]
that throw their [ __ ] Christmas tree
out like December 26th I feel like that
says a lot about you
like if I was in the FBI I would
definitely put them on like some sort of
like potential spy
right because you know they say they
have Christmas in Russia
do they know it's Christmas time at all
um
I'm not sure if they have Christmas out
there
that's a good question to ask it's
probably not a good question to ask I
could probably just Google it
um
you know those Google smart people
they always have an answer because they
have a [ __ ] smartphone but they don't
retain anything that they say
um
yeah Bill kind of like you
all right listen I'm not on this podcast
to subconsciously hear all the
[ __ ] things that you're saying about
me
um all right
and with that I'm almost at my
destination
Oh Billy old man
Billy old farts here I can wrap this up
in the next minute and a half we don't
have any reads this week
I'm surprised surprised the way I [ __ ]
on some of the advertisers just some of
their [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just so dumb you
know what I mean this is they really
gets to be a point where it's just like
are we really selling this [ __ ]
um
anyway that's the Thursday afternoon
podcast
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast
um oh I wanted to ask here's an aviation
question anybody out there fly a
Zeppelin
did any of the Goodyear Pilots
um listen to this podcast I think I
asked on the last podcast I never heard
from anybody
is the question that I have there is uh
what is the your IFR restrictions
can you get special VFR like a
helicopter can because you fly so slow
and if you have an engine failure like
what happens do you just sort of
float to the ground you slowly let these
like let the air out of the balloon
because I drove by the Rose Bowl and it
was getting pretty [ __ ] soupy out
there and those guys didn't seem like
they gave a [ __ ] or weren't concerned or
maybe the network was like you fly to
the end of the game
well you'll never fly a zeppelin again
you understand me all right that's the
podcast enjoy the music and afterward
we'll have a bonus bonus bonus a bonus
half hour episode of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast have a great weekend you
[ __ ]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
June 5th
the first Monday of the [ __ ] year
yeah
I gave you an extra one
that was for all of January
sort of held the note didn't I go [ __ ]
yourself whatever another year
another year is started I gotta be
honest with you it's still Sunday and
I'm watching the tail end of the Dallas
Detroit game I already know who wins
there's only a minute 29 left and uh I
was watching the game in real time and
uh Dallas scored to go up 24-20
so I ran upstairs to cut myself a little
piece of apple pie like the fat [ __ ]
that I'm becoming quickly and I was in
such a rush
I took the [ __ ] sorry for the echo
uh I'm downstairs and uh we don't have
any enough Furniture what do you want
from me okay it's a goal of mine
at some point
in 2015 and once I'm done paying for all
the [ __ ] horseshit that I had done
down here once I get that out of the way
maybe I can afford a [ __ ] chair
so anyway so I run up there
all right
like a typical football fan okay half a
run half a waddle breathing through my
mouth after three stairs okay after I
had the audacity to scream at the
[ __ ] TV you know like [ __ ] catch
the [ __ ] ball
now I can't even run up 10 [ __ ]
stairs winded
you know
first two steps I'm running like a 12
second 40. by the time I get to the
fifth step I'm running like a 60 second
40. it's just going downhill
so get up there chop myself out a piece
of pie and I didn't even do that I took
the lid off the thing the glass lid
thing that our neighbors got us as a uh
housewarming gift
and I wasn't even looking
and I set it half on the counter half
into air and it just shattered all over
the place I got to tell you
sweeping it up I could tell how
expensive it was you know people can
tell you that something made out of
glass is expensive but you don't realize
how expensive it is until you break it
and you're sweeping it up and you feel
that weight in the dustpan like ah that
was some quality glass
so I already know that the cowboys hang
on to win this [ __ ] game because uh
buddy of mine Keith texted me
and um
what kills me the lovely Nia
walking through
um and what kills me is uh
is all it takes is one person to walk in
the room I completely lose my train of
thought that's what kills me now what
the [ __ ] kills me
the [ __ ] was I just talking about
Nia is this is this another add thing
what oh shut up
easy as
[Music]
b-e-i-l-l-l-b-u-r [ __ ] douchebag what
was he talking about
um God damn it what the [ __ ] was I
talking to me don't walk in the room
when I'm doing the podcast all right
no I [ __ ] I was I was I was going
good there
[Music]
oh Jesus
all right anyways let's let's try to
retrace our steps all right I'm a winded
fat guy and running up the stairs
Cowboys are up I break the lid this is
some quality glass
I go to [ __ ] sweep it up
and I ended with you know what kills me
and I have no idea sevidently it wasn't
killing me
so I was exaggerating
I'm already [ __ ] bitching
in 2015 that's the heater hey can you
shut off the [ __ ] hate please
yo
can you shut up
[Music]
can you shut off the heat please
thank you
what is that sound
I like there's something about the echo
I feel like I'm in a locker room
it's fun
well it's fun for me and this is my
podcast hey you want a podcast without
screaming why don't you go [ __ ]
record one
sorry
he looks good kill
you know what Nia you got to get out I
got [ __ ] add I start looking at you
you got to get the [ __ ] out of here so I
can do the [ __ ] podcast
either grab a microphone or [ __ ] beat
it
Jesus I'm watching the end of the
Cowboys game [ __ ] let's just go with
this
you know what love whenever [ __ ] NFL
team wins a playoff game and then they
cut to the owner's box and it's always
like 12 fat white guys and J crew
pullover sweaters like
they're all [ __ ] excited
whoa
you know you know they all got a [ __ ]
their assistants are all carrying for
them
bring that [ __ ] booger sugar over to
the [ __ ] yacht you piece of [ __ ]
maybe I'll actually tip you
you're working for free someday you're
gonna work your way up in this yard this
shot facility
and they go down to the [ __ ]
well you park a [ __ ] boat yeah I'm a
yacht not done I'm not down the [ __ ]
docks right
you get down there okay
they tell their wives that they got some
whatever the [ __ ] they say and then they
go down there they got their side piece
you know
some [ __ ] chick from Switzerland
got her hair combed over in her face
like Aaliyah that chick from that movie
with the rabbit that was a cartoon but
talk to the [ __ ] guy who looked like
Bert Young
Who Framed Roger Rabbit there right and
what do they do ah they [ __ ] break it
out
the chicks just sit there they're
psyched all right they're doing blow
They're Not Gonna Wanna [ __ ] they all
are again look at him Jesus look at the
guy in the red sweater that's all stress
eating
you know why that guy in the red sweater
was that fat not because he's gluttonous
because he had to deal with Jerry Jones
wanting to draft [ __ ] Johnny Manziel
and he had to [ __ ] talk him out of it
you know I mean he just had ice cream
and short ribs for the rest of the
[ __ ] year after he dodged that bullet
so anyways
anyways let me shut off the [ __ ] TV
because this is going to be too goddamn
distracting
um by the way how many [ __ ] football
games are professional football players
gonna watch where they see a [ __ ]
jerk off
fumble the ball
and then the defensive player rather
than just falling on the [ __ ] thing
he's got to pick it up and try to be a
goddamn star
and what happens either you don't pick
it up it [ __ ] squirts away or you
[ __ ] get it slapped out of your hands
unbelievable anyways listen
congratulations to the Dallas Cowboys
and to their fans and you know what to
Tony Romo because God knows he would
have got blamed for that entire [ __ ]
loss I'll tell you that guy man don't
know what it is about them you know he
got all the [ __ ] tools and he just
got he got the smarts man that's what
the [ __ ] it is I remember one time a
long time ago I had a ranch before my
[ __ ] divorce you want to talk about
Big D [ __ ] Dallas you should see when I
played this [ __ ] [ __ ] right goddamn
[ __ ] sitting on the [ __ ] porch all
day why don't you cut up some vegetables
and put them in a pasta piece of [ __ ]
she wouldn't do it
she I tried sweet talking to Mark shut
the [ __ ] up let me finish the story this
is my story this is my [ __ ] state
that [ __ ] Tony Romo let me tell you
right now he got a look in his eye like
he a pheasant but he smells rat you know
what I'm saying
those stupid Southern Expressions I
swear to God that boy that boy
would count
ER coming up to a Goddamn
dance so anyways they've been [ __ ]
with this guy
for so goddamn long he's had like a
million [ __ ] offensive coordinators
the problem is
is what's his face Jerry Jones is an
owner
okay he's got you know you ever see a
quarterback's got little Happy Feet in
the pocket
dancing around
he can't feel the rush but he knows it's
coming got a bad feeling about this one
man that's right he's just [ __ ]
sitting there like that dude and platoon
rather than plant his [ __ ] feet
checking down the [ __ ] receivers
right like I would do if I was tall and
had Talent anyways
he's got Happy Feet as a [ __ ] owner
anybody come down the [ __ ] Pike
that's done anything in [ __ ] football
that's got a little disco ball hanging
over it he [ __ ] he can't get enough
of it
he cannot get enough of it if he would
just relax and let the coaches coach and
the players play
okay maybe slow down that elevator ride
down to the [ __ ] field I think Dallas
would be a lot further down the road
okay
you kind of you got to stop blaming your
stepson Tony Romo
whatever anyways congratulations
to the Dallas Cowboys
to their fans and to that officiating
crew that decided somewhere about four
and a half minutes to go like hey what
do you say Dallas wins this game huh you
got you're like that on three ready
break boom
how the [ __ ] was that not pass
interference
guys running down the field like he's
out of gas in the middle of nowhere
flagging down a [ __ ] car that's
coming from the other direction
clear-cut case
of [ __ ] pass interference they don't
they pick up the flag
they pick it up
then Dallas gets the [ __ ] ball
and there's more passive favorites they
don't pick up that flag I don't know
I don't know
I'm not saying it was fixed I would
never say that I'm just saying not with
bait I'm a football but I I just failed
that there was a uh you know I just
wouldn't you know come on
can you let the players win the [ __ ]
game
I don't know what the [ __ ] are you gonna
do anyways
me and Paul verzi went round
and [ __ ] around this week about some
sports [ __ ] this was this is what this
is the kind of got when you listen to
the Paul verzi effect
the furzie effect podcast
this is this is the level of intellect
of this man
I know he's gonna get pissed at me I
always do this because then he trashes
me on his podcast so here we go this is
my side of the argument this is like
listen to your parents argue through
podcasting
he [ __ ] texts me he said I think Cam
Newton's going to have a big day today
talking about when they're playing the
Arizona Cardinals
all right
and this is the deal Paul verzi said Cam
Newton was going to be a beast in the
NFL classic Paul Jersey Pick he picks
this [ __ ] guy who nobody's ever heard
of
just like a 12th round pick I mean
practically off the [ __ ] board and he
just saw something in this guy I don't
know what it was
I don't know if it was the national
championship and the Heisman Trophy I
don't know what tipped him off to the
fact that he thought that this guy was
going to be a good player but Paul verzi
he sees things
and this is what he would say well you
know a lot a lot of [ __ ] Heisman
Trophy winners don't pan out
yeah
[Music]
anyways why don't you pick the second
instead of hitching your your [ __ ]
wagon to this guy he's got his goddamn
ear stapled to the side of his [ __ ]
head all right so when anyways the nerve
for me the way I look to criticize that
guy looks like a Superman right anyways
so I put on the [ __ ] game at lo and
behold the [ __ ] Arizona Cardinals
they got a third string quarterback in
there
may God bless them but the [ __ ] guy
threw a screen pass and he fell down
he looked like me after a couple of
beers
all right of course he's gonna have a
big [ __ ] day
I know Arizona has a good defense all
right Carolina fans [ __ ] relax all
right but when the opposing team's
[ __ ] QB is falling down
because he threw the football
you gotta know there's gonna be a lot of
three and outs at which points Arizona's
defense is going to tire out at which
point Colorado Carolina is going to have
their way with them
and I'll tell you when you start doing
stuff like that you're gonna have a big
[ __ ] day and National Football League
um
anyways I didn't actually watch a lot of
uh I didn't watch a lot of sports but uh
first he was driving me up the this is
what this is what he did granted he was
[ __ ] boozing it up last night but he
[ __ ] texted me
and he's and you know I trashed him
about how he said that Babe Ruth is the
greatest [ __ ] baseball player of all
time which is absolutely [ __ ]
ridiculous and [ __ ] all you baseball
historians
okay who are going to take out your
Reams and reams of [ __ ] stats
all right
is here's the [ __ ] news I was just
thinking what's his face in uh
and uh what the [ __ ] those not Desperado
what's it called Reservoir Dogs
now here's the news
looks like say it [ __ ] hot car lot
out there
um Chris Penn one of my favorites of all
time this man this man who did his time
did it like a man
it's just gonna decide
out of the [ __ ] blue
um
to rip us off
[ __ ] I talked my way out of it now I
don't remember what the [ __ ] I was just
saying
now Jesus Christ
[ __ ] was that old version yeah yeah okay
if are you [ __ ] historians okay
if your guy played
when only white guys were allowed to
play
take 30 percent of those stats
and as The Rock Says turn it up sideways
and shove it straight up your candy ass
cause they don't [ __ ] count
okay they don't [ __ ] count
Babe Ruth [ __ ] guys getting
shit-faced banging hookers the night
before the game then he goes out throws
a no-hitter and hits four [ __ ] home
runs in the same game though that's like
a beer league
you know what I mean
give me a [ __ ] break don't you think
it's weird that that guy played a
hundred [ __ ] years ago and since he
played there's never been another guy
who could even remotely come close to
doing that
to to winning 20 games in a season and
hitting 50 [ __ ] home runs
Bo Jackson couldn't even do that and
that guy is arguably a Hall of Fame
athlete in two different professional
sports he couldn't even [ __ ] do that
you put him on the mount he would have
got [ __ ] shelved
give me a [ __ ] break here's another
thing too
I don't know if you guys have noticed
this [ __ ] but once they let
quote unquote the rest of everybody play
did you notice what happened to the
white population and everything but
hockey it [ __ ] plummeted
plummeted
all right
but when Babe Ruth played those [ __ ]
guys stayed in the league you had me
playing [ __ ] shortstop
he's no better see he's no better
foreign
listen
I'm not saying Babe Ruth wouldn't hit
[ __ ] six I'll give him 600 home runs
okay I'm not giving him over 700 I'm not
[ __ ] doing it
okay
yeah yeah yeah he maybe could have taken
Mariano Rivera deep but not every
[ __ ] time
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
give me a [ __ ] break
what a stand-up comedy was only white
guys
you know Richard Pryor Bill Cosby
[ __ ] hell Eddie Murphy just all of
those guys
all of them out the [ __ ] window
give me a [ __ ] it's the stupidest
[ __ ] argument I've ever heard in my
[ __ ] life and then to act like when
you actually let everybody [ __ ] play
that the competition isn't way more
intense
way more [ __ ] intense and to sit
there and say like dude the guys on base
percentage shut the [ __ ] up
shut I don't wanna I don't I don't even
wanna [ __ ] hear dude I'll tell you
and that goes for everybody I'm not just
picking up white guys here [ __ ] [ __ ]
will Chamberlain's 100 points in a game
all right
I find Kobe Bryant scoring over 80
points like two three [ __ ] years ago
was way more impressive than scoring 100
points
you know dunking on Bob Koozie
not saying that he's not a [ __ ] Hall
of Famer but I'm just saying come on
give me a [ __ ] break
ah Jesus I'm on a [ __ ] tie right here
and you know that's what kills me is
first he calls me up he goes yo he goes
Giannis Papas I don't know if you guys
ever seen him he's absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious okay he said Giannis Papas is
destroying your Babe Ruth argument right
now you're getting killed by Giannis
Papas right which is [ __ ] hilarious
to me it's like Paul how am I getting
killed I'm not there to [ __ ] I'm not
there to hear it I'm not there to defend
myself this guy's out there he's
punching at the air
okay this is the thing about a character
like Paul verzi and Giannis Papas all
right these fresh-faced little kids they
were born in the late 70s early [ __ ]
80s and they don't know a [ __ ] thing
that happened
before the first George Bush
Administration they don't know [ __ ]
they're the video game generation
they're rubbing one out to some [ __ ]
porn site they grew up with a screen in
their face
okay
I'm telling you go out to one of their
shows see the look in their eye if
they're twitching up there
um
this is what I would say before whenever
first he starts to annoy me and I know
it's his age I just say Paul why don't
you do me a favor why don't you go over
there go get yourself a malt and sit
down and think about what you said okay
and I actually texted him
told them to do that and I said while
you're at it why don't you go [ __ ]
buy Jana's Papa's one too and if either
one of you are listening to this clip
the next time I am in New York are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] are out here
okay
we'll all go out
we'll have a couple two or three and I
will listen to your [ __ ] argument I
want you to explain to me
how a man who never had the face
the Pedro Martinez back then the mariana
rivera that Josh Gibbs all of those guys
off the [ __ ] table
Jesus Christ it's like a [ __ ] five on
three the whole goddamn game you scored
a goal oh my God that's impressive the
[ __ ] guy he pitched no hitters and
hit 50 home runs I mean give me a
[ __ ] break he's a fat [ __ ]
me
dude you had no idea dude he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] God
definitely here
Jesus Christ
I mean look look at the [ __ ] 1920s
they didn't even not have sound in a
movie yet
and then when they did everybody was
like man why I ordered that was acting
and people got awards for that
he played baseball during that [ __ ]
time okay let me tell you something if
you played baseball when you're [ __ ]
card your baseball card was in a cigar
box go [ __ ] yourself okay I'm not saying
that you couldn't play today okay but
take 30 percent
turn them up sideways and shove them up
your [ __ ] candy ass cause I don't
want to [ __ ] hear it
all right Paul verzi
talking about his hand-eye coordination
Paul versus also the [ __ ] guy who
told me Seabiscuit was an unbelievable
athlete a [ __ ] horse
and you know why he said that because
somebody on ESPN's Paul you got to get
on this podcast because I'm actually
getting guilty I'm [ __ ] trashing you
so bad but I'm not for the simple fact
that you said somebody was killing me
when I wasn't even there to be killed
who knows Giannis might kill me
who knows he might
you know he's got that ethnic name who
the who the [ __ ] knows
he knows how to make some [ __ ]
baklovak by [ __ ] hand maybe he knows
some [ __ ] about baseball I would love to
have either one of you fresh face kids
convince me
how without a doubt Babe Ruth is the
greatest baseball player of all [ __ ]
time and I'll tell you right now I don't
want to hear a [ __ ] word about those
stats
Jesus Christ
look at look at [ __ ] basketball if
you didn't let black people in
basketball there'd be like three people
in the league
dude I gotta tell you crazy like
Johnson's back in the 40s he's going 120
points
oh God all right uh I know I know I I
[ __ ] beat it to death but I just had
to make the point spit slash bird
all right okay okay okay where the hell
are we let's get back to the podcast
here
um all right
a couple of things
uh I gotta give a shout out to Stuart
Scott everybody man that guy uh one of
the
absolute Legends of ESPN and watching
that guy over the years as he was
fighting cancer uh just the way he went
after it man I I really I mean I hope I
never get it but if I ever do I hope I
go at it the way that guy did it because
uh
that guy went out like a man that's all
I'm gonna say Stuart Scott gonna miss
you
um anyways and then I got some
good news is uh Nick de Paulo
Nick de Paulo a comedian that everybody
should be everybody should know and
every time they make those dumb [ __ ]
lists
okay who's happening who's now who's
this who's that comedy Nick depalo
should be on that [ __ ] list I don't
care how short that list is this guy is
a Comics comic and I'm actually excited
if you've never heard of the guy
um because you're gonna get to discover
the guy
um and I can give you like one of the
best comics in the [ __ ] country that
not enough people know about Nick depalo
has a brand new special out uh I'm gonna
send you the link
and all of that type of stuff we'll have
that up on the podcast page and if you'd
like to Google and uh search him uh it's
Nick
and then depaolo is Di and then space
Capital
p-a-o-l-o Nick de Paulo uh
absolutely [ __ ] Fearless
and uh I did a tour of them a long time
ago I told this story when I did Nick
and Artie's show a long time ago I did
um
I'd done the uh the Montreal Comedy
Festival in the Montreal Comedy Festival
Just for Laughs is
like huge
up in Canada
but you know people are starting to get
to know him down here but they had no
idea who they were like 10 years ago
when I went on this [ __ ] tour
and um it was a sick tour too it was
Nick de Paulo
me Greg Geraldo rest of Soul uh Tom Papa
Gary gulman
who else was on it I mean it was just it
was just to kill a bunch of comics all
great guys everybody having a good time
and I used to watch Nick when Nick would
go out there
all of a sudden like his chin would drop
down to his chest and he'd almost be
looking through his eyebrows and he
would just be going back and forth
looking through the crowd all the way
from stage right slowly all the way to
stage left
stage left slowly back all the way over
to Stage right I used to watch him do
this every [ __ ] night as he's telling
these killer jokes I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he doing when he's backstage
his head is you know he's got level
flight here he goes out there his nose
down what the [ __ ] is going on right and
I finally realized what it was because
the material he did
inevitably somebody was going to scream
out at him so what he was doing was he
was ducking down he was shielding his
face his eyes from the stage light so he
could see who said what so he could tear
him a new [ __ ] [ __ ] I think I said
on Artie's show he was like a security
camera just going back and forth he's
one of my favorite comics
of all time and he's a great [ __ ] guy
um
so anyways when I when I do the Patrice
O'Neill benefit next month I'm going to
try to get him on he's out here
I know we did Joe Rogan's he did Adam
carollas and uh I think he did Jay
Moore's podcast too he was trying to set
something up with me but he was all
he's all backed up or whatever just
didn't work out between us so that sucks
for me uh and my podcast and my
listeners but I promise you I'm gonna
get him on probably in the next month I
got to make it happen
um
because it would be an honor to have him
on he's just [ __ ] awesome so anyways
moving on
um all right well I went to another Rose
Bowl everybody
and I think I'm just now starting to
recover first of all what a [ __ ] game
I um
just the like the Rose Bowls are already
unbelievable but to add that whole
playoff [ __ ] atmosphere to it
was just insane and uh
this year me and all the guys we got
over there we were so [ __ ] organized
this year
we we had we had [ __ ] everything
we had [ __ ] everything food booze
other stuff
[Music]
Jason lawhead put on a display
of tailgate cooking that it was he had a
career year that's what we were saying
he had a breakout it was just [ __ ] on
it was the best breakfast sandwich I
ever had
then he made these ribs that were
unbelievable then we went to the game
and at the end of the game it was
freezing out by then and we were smart
that's how smart we were we brought a
cord of wood
and one of the grills we turned into
just like a fire pit and everybody else
who was waiting for the traffic all
these people were coming and gathering
around our little fire
going you guys are smart oh this is
really smart what I left out is we
brought everything except fire we forgot
to bring a lighter they were bringing
the grills and they were bringing the
charcoal so I assumed that they were
going to bring the [ __ ] lighter and I
brought the ladder every year so I guess
that one was on me I don't know what but
other than that
it was a
it was another amazing time and um
[ __ ] hilarious we basically we get
into the game got in on time because
it's a [ __ ] playoff game right and
there was so many people getting tickets
that I couldn't get four together I got
two and two so we were like a couple
rows two three rows in front of uh
bartnick and lawhead and we're sitting
there you know and I'm pretty I'm not as
bad as I was last year but I was [ __ ]
uh I was feeling no pain all right I was
definitely more than dehydrated at that
point and all of a sudden I see security
walking out with Jason lawhead
and there's no Joe bartnick and Jay is
looking at him over at me with his hands
like up like what the [ __ ] and he's
yelling at me and I'm going Jake
way they take it I mean like I'm in the
middle of this [ __ ] row there's like
30 people on one side 30 on the other
this Old School Stadium right total
[ __ ] fire hazard right I'm like Jake
where you go Jake and he's [ __ ]
yelling me I can't hear
and that you're whisking him out so fast
there's nothing I could do other than I
just keep going J J
looking at me like what the [ __ ]
turns out
uh
I don't know bartnick was outside he was
in the stadium but outside the stands I
guess he had sat down or something
and nodded off and when he came to there
was like [ __ ] 20 cops surrounding him
because he's such a big guy I thought
they were like they were like what if
this guy starts Swinging with [ __ ]
and they went down there and they told
I guess they looked at his ticket they
went up to get Jason that's what they
did and they said we got he's been over
served which is the understatement for
all of us for 2015.
and uh law head to his credit the only
thing he did better than cooking was
talk his way out of that
he just kept going come on look at the
guy he he's a teddy bear he's not he's
not hurting anybody he's gonna go up
days and sit down he's going to be he's
he just kept saying he's a teddy bear
and Joe was just looking hey you know
him I'm a teddy bear
so you know
they [ __ ] let him in
[ __ ] law I had the politician gets
him to his seat
he sits in his seat and then promptly
[ __ ] passes out
and some lady behind the law head goes
hey you're going to have to get him out
of here
and Jay just looked at him and said hey
come on
he's not hurting anybody he's a teddy
bear okay listen and she [ __ ] jot
back at him and Jay was just like listen
if tell you what if you will just watch
the game you're not even going to see
him okay I mean I can wake him up if you
want me to I'll wake him up I don't
think you're gonna like it but I can't
wake him up and people just started
laughing and it was over and we had a
wonderful time
I'm seeing two of the top college
football programs play each other it's a
hell of a game through two and a half
quarters and then uh
Oregon I gotta give a shout out to the
Ducks just for shutting up
the FSU band and I didn't have to hear
that that [ __ ] tomahawk chop again
and I I dude I [ __ ] called it that
band
knows three songs they know the school
song they play something else and then
everything else
the whole [ __ ] game
and um
it was I mean I don't know I would like
to see a little bit of a closer game but
uh I really enjoyed uh the fact that
they shut that band up nothing against
FSU I actually really like the seminals
and I've always loved that program but
um somewhere along the line that
Tomahawk chopped just [ __ ]
it would be like if at the Red Sox like
you know how awful it is when they sing
Sweet Caroline just imagine if they did
that between every [ __ ] inning I mean
you'd want to kill yourself right if you
want any sort of a human being that
includes being a Red Sox fan because I
want to jump off the [ __ ] monster
when I hear that [ __ ] song just once
oh you're looking around and [ __ ]
women putting their head on the [ __ ]
guy's shoulder it's just like ah
I don't know well maybe I don't know
maybe I should be a little more positive
about just [ __ ] like that I have no idea
um
what else so it's a new year do I have
any um
New Year's resolutions uh yeah I'm
actually gonna TR it's [ __ ] hilarious
with this podcast I'm gonna try to lose
my [ __ ] a little bit less
uh especially when I drive
I um
you know what really I know this is an
old comedy bit here but what really
[ __ ] bothers me this this is the I'm
you know rather than just saying
straight across the board I'm going to
lose
I'm gonna I'm gonna stop losing my [ __ ]
when I drive I'm just pick picking
moments
like you know what I'm I'm not going to
flip out about anymore
is when there's traffic on the highway
and that person in front of you leaves
like a four card Gap in front of them
I'm just pausing right now for anybody
who just wanted to go like oh I [ __ ]
hate that guy I know I [ __ ] hate that
guy too we all hate that [ __ ] guy
unless you are that guy is anybody that
guy who listens to this podcast and for
the sanity
of the other 98 of the people on the
planet can you please explain
your [ __ ] rationale
I'm not gonna lose my [ __ ] can you
please explain
your mindset as to why you feel that you
have to leave that big of a gap
you know and I was actually sitting
behind this guy and I was starting to
lose my [ __ ] and I go I'm not gonna lose
my [ __ ] and I just sat in my head this
guy
rather than saying he's texting rather
than saying he's a [ __ ] I just said
this guy's gotten into a major accident
and he broke his [ __ ] hip and he
doesn't want it to happen again so he's
letting other people go
okay
just [ __ ] and I hate that whole
mentality like why I mean what are we
actually saving huh in the end of the
day I mean well what's what's another
car length you know what it is it's it's
soothing
okay
it's it's a cold drink of water on a hot
summer's day just to move another
[ __ ] foot all right kid you know what
that's what I do is any anybody out
there one of those [ __ ] people can
you explain please explain to me why you
do that maybe if I know why you do that
then I can actually understand you more
as a person and then I won't
be beside myself because you don't see
the world the way I do how about that is
that more mature
and while we're at it
people out here in La who ride bicycles
and those clusters of 20 [ __ ] people
like you're having a bike race that
nobody else wants no nobody else knows
about
why do you feel that you're allowed to
ride out in the road like that I've
asked cops you're not allowed to do that
or why do you ride side by side the two
of you so you can shoot the [ __ ] and
you're slowing people down behind you
I'm just asking don't you feel it's a
little hypocritical if you want the
[ __ ] car to share the road that you
don't share the [ __ ] road
and while we're at it why are you
dressed up with like sponsors on you
like anybody's paying you to ride that
[ __ ] ah Jesus Christ there goes the
temple all right let's get to some
questions here for the week um
the Rose Bowl everybody
oh dude I'll tell you right now if
you're gonna pick a beer to start the
day with I'm telling you Miller High
Life uh in a in the you got to get it in
the bottle
oh my God the sun's just coming up we
got that 704 in the [ __ ] morning it
was freezing cold out there was a frost
on the fairways I'm telling you guys you
gotta [ __ ] do this okay you don't got
to go to the Rose Bowl [ __ ] pick
something
that you and all you dumb guy friends do
are you and all your dumb [ __ ] women
friends just you gotta have that one
thing you do every year
you gotta have that I don't give a [ __ ]
what kind of responsibility you got out
you gotta have that one [ __ ] thing so
anyways we got there the frost was on
the [ __ ] Fairways
I actually said this year when I got out
I said hey guys guys gotta go take this
in right here this is the best part of
the tailgate it's the beginning
and this time tomorrow you're gonna wish
that that this [ __ ] moment will
actually know because you'll be too
hungover three days later when you get
all the poison out of your system you're
gonna be [ __ ] longing for that
feeling
do we get out of that truck
ear to ear [ __ ] Grinch
and then bartik's got this thing that he
yells out to everybody to the entire
parking lot
um I don't want to say what it is
because he yells it so [ __ ] loud and
so far nobody's ever found our [ __ ]
tailgate which has been great because we
make a spectacle of ourselves
um you got to do it so anyways the Rose
Bowl let's let's read this thing here uh
dear Billy football
uh love the podcast your new special was
nothing short of amazing thank you very
much and thank you everybody who's been
watching it re-watching it and telling
other people to watch my new special you
people are all the same I'm sorry Jesus
Christ I'm sorry you feel that way
oh Jesus bill
um
I really appreciate it because uh this
one has been getting the best response
and uh you know that makes me look good
with the people I'm in business with
over there at Netflix so uh you guys did
me a solid I really appreciate it all
right
um
anyways anyways here we go anyway I had
a question about your Rose Bowl outing
last weekend the game itself was great
from that opening Oregon drive when
Mariota I hope that's how you say his
name I didn't it's too Heisman Trophy
winners I don't even know their [ __ ]
names I was so busy this year
I did and I was so hammered I even had a
[ __ ] program I had no idea uh Mariota
pitched it to the guy who somersaulted
to the one yard line F and later
completed the two-point conversion oh
that was great at the beginning
um to famous James flopping around
fumbling for an Oregon touchdown late in
the third it was just a great game and I
was thoroughly jealous you were there
you're obviously in Oregon uh Ducks fan
uh my question is
can you share with us a couple of your
favorite moments from this year's Rose
Bowl I kind of did that but there's
probably some more I'm sure you had you
and the Goon Squad you roll around with
uh
got in some funny situations of
conflicts P.S I saw a lawhead and
bartnick in Boston for the all things
Comedy Tour they were great guys and had
the pleasure of sitting with bartnick at
the bar while Jay crushed it on stage
cool dudes I would love to drink and
smoke stoves
with you all sometime happy New Year and
go [ __ ] yourself you apron wearing [ __ ]
yeah it was a good one you bastard um
I think I've already told the uh
the stores yeah throwing the football
the food I mean I don't know I was
pretty sober but I was kind of a
consistent leveled like blacked out
um
I don't know what what was it this year
just the whole [ __ ] thing you know
what's cool is watching a father with
his two sons and he was playing
automatic QB and teaching his kid the
cornerback to get inside you know inside
the receiver and uh watching the big
brother older brother [ __ ] rivalry
reminded me when I was a kid
I sat there smiling drinking a beer
probably looked like a pedophile but I
was actually thinking nothing but clean
stuff everybody looks like a pedophile
now
um
I don't know
I got to be honest with you the whole
[ __ ] day is a goddamn blur I remember
most of the game I did I passed out a
little bit in the first quarter for
about a minute and a half football time
and then the second quarter for about a
minute and a half but uh other than that
you know I crushed waters for the rest
of the [ __ ] game I didn't have any
beers afterwards because I had to drive
and that's by then you know we stayed
there till like 8 30 9 o'clock at night
so by then I haven't drank in like eight
hours so I'm actually so sober I'm
[ __ ] hungover at that point
[Music]
um
so anyways uh Australian beaches built
you talk about sharks and how they eat
people constantly is this going to keep
you out of the water in Australia ah you
know what I'd love to say yes
but I know if we have time my wife loves
the ocean and um
I gotta be honest with you man I've
never seen beaches like in Australia
last time I was there
um which was two years ago this past
October I was in Sydney
and we took we took a walk along the
coastline and
um and it was really Rough Waters and
stuff but it was so [ __ ] beautiful
the only thing that stopped me was it
was freezing cold out in the rough water
and I'm [ __ ] terrified of you know
you swim in an ocean it's [ __ ] alive
okay
this one in a pool there's nothing in
there that can eat you and then also
like there's no like undercurrent
Riptide and all of that [ __ ] you know
the ocean just doesn't itself doesn't
decide that it wants to kill you
um
will I go into it yeah probably uh
but no more than up to my waist and then
I'll go back and I'll be freaking out
that there's something [ __ ] swimming
along there
um I do have to tell you since flying
helicopters you can't believe what the
[ __ ] is out there just off the shore
um everything from like you know
a group of porpoises jumping out of the
[ __ ] water
which is cool to see and then you'll
just see some big [ __ ] thing by
itself and you're like was that a shark
is that a whale what the [ __ ] is that
and you'll look like diagonally up like
I don't know about a half a mile and
there's a bunch of people sitting on
surfboards waiting to [ __ ] catch a
wave and uh
I am I'm all set on that I'm all [ __ ]
set on that
um
so anyways uh baking
hey geez I'm [ __ ] tearing through
these goddamn questions
oh no we got 46 minutes in okay plus I
got some other topics I can talk about
anyways baking Bill I'm a 34 year old
husband and father
of a two-year-old boy
I work hard and our family is doing well
the hard work does take a toll and at
the end of the day I had a heart I have
a hard time winding down because work is
always racing through my mind
hearing about you baking gave me the
idea to try the same ah Jesus look what
I'm doing to men in this country here's
another guy going to go buy an apron
um don't even listen to these [ __ ]
[ __ ] one of the coolest things you
can do is go out in the kitchen and make
a [ __ ] killer goddamn meal I swear to
God we gave we we applauded Jason
lawhead more than we did those [ __ ]
teams the level this guy was cooking all
right I guess it's more manly [ __ ]
because it's out on an open flame
all of that type of [ __ ] but whatever
dude put on a [ __ ] apron make a
goddamn pie and pan sear a [ __ ] pork
chop and then talk to me anyways at
night now after my kid goes to bed and
my wife and I are hanging out I'll make
a bread or a pie
every night dude you're gonna be a house
he goes I'm getting really particular
about my techniques now and take pride
in the little things it's very Zen
absolutely uh one in five or six baking
sessions I'll take a small hit off a
joint and it's a perfect evening thanks
for exposing me to the idea and laughing
at yourself when people on Twitter make
comments about you being some type of
Sally
[Laughter]
I gotta be honest with you that [ __ ]
always makes me laugh anybody calls me
Twinkle Toes or a Sally that is always
[ __ ] made me laugh I don't give a
[ __ ]
um and he says anyways it beats getting
one of those small Japanese Rock Gardens
from my desk thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's great man I would just be
careful about making pies and bread
every day you'll be you'll be a you'll
be a [ __ ] house but uh
I don't know man I'm actually gonna try
to learn
some vegetarian main courses so I can
offset
everything else that I'm learning how to
do like I want to learn how to make a
[ __ ] uh a Sunday gravy
um because I already know how to make
pasta homemade pasta and I'm gonna get a
ravioli maker and I'm gonna do something
like that or make some rigatoni
break a [ __ ] antney over there and
I'm gonna uh I want to make a Sunday
gravy or something like that which I'm
dying to do all I'm kind of afraid of
canned tomatoes
because I know then they don't taste
good and they're also they're really bad
for you and uh
all I have I have two tomato plants
out my front yard and uh
you know
what they yield I [ __ ] eat I don't
jar any of those things but I'm
obviously I'm like a closet [ __ ]
Italian here because I actually want to
get a decent number of tomato plants out
in my front yard and then just [ __ ]
you know as they become right obviously
picked them and then I was gonna you
know skin the [ __ ] things and then
mush them into a jar and then jar them
and then have tomatoes for my sauce all
[ __ ] year that's what I want to do
rather than getting these [ __ ]
Tomatoes I've been in cans for years and
God knows what they do to you you know
you hear [ __ ] right so anyways uh
congratulations sir it's a great thing
to do and any young people out there all
right
men and women women cooking is a lost
[ __ ] art I don't know why you guys
ever stopped doing it nothing will shut
your guy up [ __ ] quicker than making
him a great goddamn meal here eat it and
go [ __ ] yourself it's over he's gonna
have that in his head
this is not new information
women knew that a long time ago then
somewhere along the line when they
started growing out their [ __ ] snatch
air and they quit using deodorant
burning their bras that whole [ __ ]
thing
uh you know they they they
forgot some good things like hey you
know make the guy a [ __ ] sandwich
every once in a while watch them shut
the [ __ ] up they just won't do it but
anyways guys
telling you
I'm telling you right now
all right
tell me if I could [ __ ] cook the way
it cooked now back when I was a single
[ __ ] man it would have been over
one of my big regrets in life I didn't
learn how to make a pie crust until I
was in a committed relationship God damn
it what an [ __ ] uh girlfriend says
girlfriends keep sex tape from previous
relationship everybody
let's see where this one's going okay oh
this is this one has oh Jesus written
all over it hey Bill I've been listening
for the past three years I love the
podcast especially when you freak out
and throw tantrums and call yourself out
by name he says in parentheses oh really
bill yeah I guess I do that those are
the best ones I have a situation I got a
situation
that might be of interest to you my
girlfriend of almost a year has a sex
tape
uh uh my girlfriend of almost a year has
a sex tape with with her previous
boyfriend
what in the past she was very insecure
and weak
very impressionable
I believe this is why she was ever
talked into such a thing
but maybe I don't give her enough credit
I can accept that she made one in her
past her experiences made her who she is
oh Jesus
however
she made the decision to keep this tape
anyways after the fact she says I like
keeping things that remind me of people
and moments that made me smile even if
they were mistakes and didn't work out
I'll go [ __ ] yourself yeah dude why
don't you try the same thing
why don't you try the same thing
oh my God what a [ __ ] you know I gotta I
gotta almost stopping a plotter for that
[ __ ] lie she also says
that she wants to watch this tape as she
gets older because she will want to
remember when she had a great body
he said I kind of manipulated her into
showing me this tape what the [ __ ]
by telling her that I think it's hot and
that it might turn me on
she had only been shy about mentioning
it mentioning it in the past kind of
teasing
but maybe she was just afraid of my
reaction and was testing how I was
reacting all right this is my fear sir
my fear is
that your girlfriend is a freak
and she keeps meeting guys
that are not relationship guys so now
that
she's met you
you know this is our own little [ __ ]
freak thing that she kind of keeps and
uh I'm worried that she's going to be
doing [ __ ] and this guy's gonna be doing
stuff to her that you have not done or
even thought about doing okay in other
words I'm waiting for you I'm worried
you're gonna see a load on her face
all right there that's my concern all
right
when I saw it
I felt so repulsed it was the unsexiest
thing I've ever seen all right well it
went the other way she was traumatized
too very traumatized so I kept my cool
and calmed her down before I had to head
home wait a minute
so she pops this thing in you guys are
both horrified
and did she start crying and then you
shut it off it had to be like no no it
was no big deal but you know
I'll call you tomorrow
I don't mean to laugh sir but it's just
like this is supposed to be a funny
podcast so I got to keep the comedy
coming in
oh my God Jesus Christ all right here we
go now she says
that I act weird
and that she is sorry that she hurt me
but she doesn't apologize about keeping
this tape nor have I asked it to I think
it's beside the point
if she only does it to appease me
oh she she has to get rid of it because
she wants to
is what you're saying am I reacting out
of a bruised Macho ego
I could never imagine keeping a sex tape
from another relationship while I'm in a
new one yeah
I don't even keep the normal photos
tagged on my Facebook what's your advice
and maybe Nia can add her opinion too
since she might think I'm being
possessive or judgmental
it would mean a lot to get your advice
thanks a lot and go [ __ ] yourself well
she's upstairs and he's heard of Marty
driving her [ __ ] nuts
um
no dude you're not you're not this is
completely [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up and it's weird
that she would keep that [ __ ] tape
it's [ __ ] weird dude and like come on
man
can you imagine saying that to your
girlfriend
hey I got a sex tape from the last woman
I used to hook up with but uh I just
keep it you know because I like to keep
things
from my past that you know remind me of
things that I've done even if they were
my mistakes but you know at the end of
the day it just kind of makes me smile
she it would just be dead silence she
would just she would be what the what
the [ __ ] did you just say
and then as you start at the top she'd
tell you to shut the [ __ ] up as she
proceeded to break up with you
because to me that that's like
it's
it's bizarre this is this isn't fair
because I'm reading this I didn't hear
how she said it I don't know anything
about her but that's [ __ ] bizarre
that's not it's just not cool
um
it'd be bad enough if you somehow found
it
but at least she had the decency to keep
it a secret but the fact that she even
[ __ ] tells you about it just makes me
smile
you know like like she has a [ __ ]
quilt her grandmother made
I don't know dude I don't think I think
you got to be like look you need to get
[ __ ] get rid of that thing okay
that's [ __ ] up
okay and and [ __ ] your fragile state
okay [ __ ] your state what about my state
all right
get rid of the [ __ ] thing
that's what I would say put down all the
[ __ ] and the anger get rid of the
[ __ ] thing
I know dude that's [ __ ] weird
all right
next one oh wait you know let me read
the last bit of advertising and then
I'll knock this one out I'll [ __ ]
some more and that'll be a podcast for
the week
oh for [ __ ] sakes here we go
and I'm gonna use LegalZoom when I do it
there you go there see there you don't
have the right copy for me I [ __ ] do
it myself
I do it myself all right 22 year old
hitting on 26 year old manager
what the [ __ ] wrong with that
22 year old hitting on his 20 on on 26
year old manager
there's nothing wrong with that hello
Bill long time listener here and I'm
writing to you today for some advice I'm
a 23 year old man and currently have the
hots for a 26 year old manager
just a little background she's
originally from Louisiana and is smoking
hot I love her already
she just moved here around a year ago
and always complains to me about being
lonely because she does not know many
people here in Cali [ __ ] dude
she's laying it right on the table for
you what is she gonna do [ __ ] throw
her legs in the air
first of all you said you're 22. now
you're telling me you're 23. anyways
she's always being extra nice to me like
buying me buying lunches always checking
up on me and staying a while to chat and
gives me the eyes from time to time
where do you live in the country you
might be mistaking her Southern
Hospitality because you're used to some
[ __ ] cold East Coast women
the [ __ ] you looking at you [ __ ]
douchebag right and all of a sudden she
comes up you want to know napkin
dude she wants to suck it
just make sure it's not that anyways
um
me considering myself a pretty handsome
guy I was thinking if I have a shot
thinking if I have a shot or
what come on guys I suck at reading you
gotta proofread these things I was
thinking if I have a shot or am I just
over my head here no you're not
totally have a shot just this new year
she was constantly complaining about she
had no invitations to New Year's dude
this woman is throwing it at you
so me making a joke since I also did not
have any plans said hey maybe we should
hang out and get and drink some wine
you think I can have a shot if so how
would I go about hanging out
at her place I live with my parents ah
Jesus or am I taking her kindness for
flirting oh Jesus dude Jesus we got to
get you in the game
thanks again Bill great seeing you with
the eighth house all right egg two
you know we got to do you know what I'm
going to do right now I'm going to make
you I gotta get you to stand up straight
okay
don't ever say maybe
you know maybe we should in our hand if
there's no maybe
you got to tell it let's hang out
don't say it like that say yeah you dumb
[ __ ] don't say it like that
yeah just tell her let's hang out let's
have some [ __ ] wine let's say what do
you want to do I'll show you around town
I'll say that I'll show you around town
and you're the [ __ ] friend
Jesus Christ have I been in a
relationship this [ __ ] long
I would just [ __ ] come up to work and
just say listen
wait she's your manager
who gives a [ __ ] dude you're 23. have
you [ __ ] a manager yet you gotta [ __ ]
one boss
and see what that does to your [ __ ]
professional and personal life you
learned that lesson you'll be a better
man because of it you just gotta [ __ ]
she's already throwing it at you you got
to tell her you're gonna hang out then
you got the [ __ ] out too because
she's your boss be like hey we can't get
too [ __ ] hot and heavy here because
they had the whole business thing right
plus she's three four years older than
you you know what I mean
I think she's just looking for somebody
to [ __ ] hang out with and uh give her
a nice one you know what I'm saying oh
Jesus Christ Bill that was [ __ ] that
was very piggish
that was very piggish but you're totally
in the game okay
she's smoking hot she's got that
southern accent this is [ __ ] killing
it's killing me right now that you're
not banging her yet all right and you
know what whoever [ __ ] any [ __ ] woman
who's offended by saying that too
that I said that all right Jesus Christ
can they [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore
good Lord every [ __ ] two days on the
internet there's another article about
what men are doing wrong
I'm gonna give women in general advice
and stop rolling your [ __ ] eyes at me
okay you're getting makeup all over your
eyebrows
all right listen to me
this is what you need to do
stop telling men that you don't give a
[ __ ] anymore about what they think okay
the mere fact that you're taking the
time to do that means you give a [ __ ]
just just [ __ ]
do your own [ __ ]
if you sick of guys running [ __ ] start
your own [ __ ] for the life of me
I don't know why they don't go out and
start their own [ __ ] more often
look at look at look at the [ __ ]
women I guess in my business
I can think of like three right now
who's [ __ ] rather than sitting around
there's no good rules for women they sat
down wrote a [ __ ] script and got the
[ __ ] thing made and now they're
calling the shots that's what you do
actually man man or woman
that's what the [ __ ] you do but this
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] where you you sit
there
and
you say what's wrong with your life
by criticizing the other sex all that
okay uh my recorder [ __ ] the bed
or God is a feminist
um picky the one
I uh I just listened to the beginning of
the podcast and heard that I did say
June 5th instead of January 5th so I'm
sure you guys are all attacking me on
Twitter now enjoying making fun of me
yet again this year uh Happy New Year to
everybody go [ __ ] yourselves I hope you
have a wonderful week I'm nervous about
the Patriots playing the Ravens they got
a hell of a defense and uh